when i when i lectured to you last i i
pointed out
i described nietzsche and dostoevsky's
summation of the world situation and
really the world psychological situation
at the end of the 1800s and that was
that
our new modes of thinking had undermined
our faith in our old modes of thinking
and that was a problem because people
need something firm to stand on to
orient themselves and to move forward
and so nietzsche and dostoevsky
basically both prophesied that the
consequence of that dissolution would be
increased probability of nihilism and
everything that went along with that
and dostoevsky wrote about that actually
quite extensively in a book called
notes from underground which if any of
you are interested especially in
clinical psychology
that's a book you should really read
because it's one of the most brilliant
psychological studies of a of a of a
psychologically disturbed man that's
ever been written
it's very accurate and there are
sections in crime and punishment that
are like that too i think they're
unsurpassed in their representation of
of site of psychological phenomena
i don't i don't know how he managed it i
mean dostoevsky was epileptic i don't
know if you know that but
he um he was arrested by the tsar's men
in the late 1800s for being a student
radical
and uh they threw him in that main
prison in
in moscow and then one day they took him
out
in front of a firing squad and shot him
at six in the morning but they only used
blanks which of course he didn't know
about and
that scared him so badly he developed
epilepsy and then he had epileps that
can happen by the way
um and then he had epilepsy for the rest
of his life but he had this strange kind
of epilepsy which is
actually not all that rare sometimes
when people have epilepsy they
they experience this phenomena they call
an aura which is an altered state of
consciousness before the epileptic
seizure hits and they can be very
strange these auras so
i read a case study once about a guy who
um
his aura was that his hand was being
possessed by devils from hell
and he could feel the possession move up
his arm and into his shoulder and once
it hit his head he'd have an epileptic
seizure
and so then there was another case
where where this man his aura was that
his exact double had appeared behind him
but if he turned and if he turned to
look then he'd have an epileptic seizure
but if he didn't turn to look then he
wouldn't
so these you know brain disorders are
very strange things because they're
well the system that is disordered is
alive and it's capable of any number of
extraordinarily peculiar misbehaviors
anyways dostoevsky's
aura was a world revealing aura and so
what dostoevsky would experience was
that
the meaning of things got deeper and
deeper and deeper and deeper and deeper
and
then just as he was on the verge of
discovering the secret to everything
he'd have an epileptic seizure but he
said that the quality of experience
during the aura was so
high so overpowering and so deep that he
would have
traded all of his normal experience just
to have had those experiences and he had
them repeatedly and
i really do believe that it was this
broadening of his
of his vision and concept by his
epilepsy that transformed him among
other things i mean he went through some
pretty damn rough experiences because he
was imprisoned with
rapists and murderers for a long time in
siberia even though he was kind of an
aristocratic guy i mean he had a
he had a rough time of it and i i
imagine that that also
broadened him tremendously given that it
didn't kill him
but i really do believe that the
epileptic insight
was key to his like his unsurpassed
genius
and so and the his aura and other people
do experience epileptic
aura symptoms like that by the way and
some people are so enamored of the aura
that they won't take their anti-epilepsy
medication because they don't want to
forego the
experience that precedes the aura or the
actual
actual epileptic seizure so dostoevsky's
experiences
the the aw element of the aura is also
relevant to what we're going to talk
about today because
both bin swanger and and boss were very
interested in how meaning revealed
itself in the world
and they had no they had opposing
explanations
i actually think they're parallel
explanations but
um the meaning that dostoevsky
experienced is
is an amplification of the normal manner
in which meaning reveals itself in the
world
so i mean and and people experience that
sort of thing in in various
altered states of consciousness